so jd vance has announced his run for
senate
um in ohio now jd vance is the guy who
wrote
hillbilly elegy and now he's running for
office
um and he's had a really rough go of it
in the first couple days
so during his announcement speech the
the placard the sign in front of the
podium that says your name and why
you're running
fell down mid-speech did you see this
carly
i felt bad for his staff
because jd vance did not put that sign
there himself so some poor schmuck who's
working for davey fans it's like this
was my one job
and when you're the speaker and the sign
falls you can't it's not like in your
it's not like in your radar really it's
either behind you or in this case in
front of you in front of the podium so
you can't really tell people laugh or
you can't tell it's so awkward don't
uncomfortable
but when we were running frawley andrew
frawley was our uh digital director he
ended up being our merch
merch director um in the early days we
were hanging up a yang 2020 banner
behind andrew
and he had used like an excessive amount
of tape and like string like get it up
there like probably like really got that
sign locked down
he's like dude number one rule
if you've got a sign it cannot fall down
[Music]
on today's episode of yang speaks carly
riley is joining the chat with me your
co-host zach rauman
it's kind of a lighthearted episode
today we're talking about our takes on
jd
vance on bill cosby and shikari
richardson
and we also have a debate that i want
you guys to embrace
on whether or not it is worth your time
to make your freaking bed
people have hot takes on this i have hot
takes on this carly and i get into it
right now on yang speaks
[Music]
welcome everyone to thursday's episode
of yang
speaks back by popular demand we have
carly riley folks
she's a fan favorite y'all love her so
we brought her back in to talk about
some of our
favorite topics i'm pretty sure we
didn't bring you on to let you talk in
the third person
i'm confident that was not part of the
discussion
but everything else is true this is my
zachary all right folks
back by popular demand carly riley
talk about the topics of the week what's
going on we got some good stuff for
y'all
hope you had a happy fourth of july got
to spend some time with your families
are you still impersonating me yes okay
we have stuff to talk about
we got big big news um in the news this
week and i figured we'd dive in so let's
start
first things first bill cosby is a free
man
and i feel like the world has thoughts
do you have thoughts
i have plenty of thoughts and i have
plenty i have predictions which i want
to talk about but maybe carly summarize
let's give a summary for those of us who
uh who tune in and don't listen to the
news every day and why bill cosby's free
yeah uh it's basically a legal
technicality
so as far as i understand it back
when the various trials you know builds
various trials were going on there was a
civil case
and a criminal case against him and the
prosecutor on the civil case
basically made a deal with cosby and
said
if you comply with things or admit to
guilt
if you admit to guilt okay that's what
it was if you admit to guilt in this
civil case
you will not be tried criminally cosby
agreed
and then lo and behold he was tried
criminally found guilty and went to jail
and now x number of years later they've
reviewed all of that the courts have
reviewed all of that and said okay that
was unjust because this agreement was
made with this prosecutor it was
actually not legal that we try you
criminally so you are now
free so there nobody is saying here he
is not guilty
nobody is saying he did not do what he
was convicted of
it is truly a case of our criminal
system and our court system
uh sort of not working in this
particular instance or working as it's
intended
to but not working for the public good
um
so 50 women plus i believe have accused
bill cosby of um
drugging and or raping them they've come
out and accused him of foul play
of various forms some very very serious
and some um
just kind of dark and disgusting and the
harsh reality is um
the fact of the matter is he has not
been convicted of a crime
um that's where we stand right now
here's my prediction
um so a couple things but it's like
the plead guilty or plead guilty to this
and we won't try you criminally for the
civil case as much as that sounds like
shady backroom deals that happens often
um surprise so victims get something i
don't necessarily mind that
rule per se it's just what in this case
is it wasn't written down
like i'm i'm not clear and yeah it was a
verbal agreement it was like a verbal
agreement that they have now honored
which seems a little sus to me not
i don't actually think there's something
suspicious going on here i don't think
there's some like illuminati pulling
strings for bill cosby behind the scenes
but
it is frustrating to me that this was a
non-written agreement
that now has to be upheld and
uh i i that the prosecutor who was
trying to put him in jail
verbally you know he wasn't trying to
put him in jail it was a civil case he
wasn't trying to put him in jail the
prosecutor was trying to get him money
out of him for these things right
whatever he was
against him anyway but i get what you're
saying um my prediction
is and i think bill cosby said something
this is that um
he's gonna make comeback and he will
have um i do think there will be a
sadly i believe he'll profit off this i
agree he'll profit like the dude's out
of jail he'll do something and make some
amount of money
you were saying that you thought he was
gonna you know just
rake it in he's doing is he doing
another comedy special i don't know he
hasn't said anything i believe he's
technically
legally blind your prediction had been
oh he's going to do another comedy
special and like
louis i think he will yes and a
documentary i don't know
i think that documentary seems more
likely to me i don't think you're gonna
have a lot of people paying for a bill
cosby comedy special at this point
like he's not louis ck like you were
like oh well louis c.k made a bunch of
money off of his comedy special louis
c.k was like
masturbating in front of women who some
of whom said like
they were okay with it at the time like
it's not the same as drugging and raping
that's like a whole different level two
levels of terrible here
100 but i think if bill cosby put on
billcosby.com
a comedy special i bet you a lot of
people would pay for it
um a lot of people pay for it just to it
would be
just to see what he says yeah um because
we haven't heard a lot from him
specifically
um and that's kind of the world we live
in well and that's that's an important
part of the prediction is this is not
like
netflix is suddenly gonna like pay bill
cosby several millions to do a netflix
comedy special or hbo like these
institutions aren't gonna touch this
dude
i would imagine um i would be shocked if
they did
but he can he can do it on his own site
and
what's his like social media following
that's a question because he has to
publicize this somehow
i don't know um i'm sure the press pick
it up anyway
that's what's happening in the bill
cosby world the other thing um i wanted
to get your take on
um because it ties into i think our
sweet spot which is a tie between
a pop culture um
politics and the left and the right
working together
so jd vance has announced his run for
senate
um in ohio now jd vance is the guy who
wrote
hillbilly elegy um so if you may not
heard of jd vance you may not heard of
hillbilly elegy but you may have heard
of the documentary that came out
which i believe was critically acclaimed
and you've probably heard
about this guy who came out of
trump's america and made it into our
elite institutions and then wrote a book
to tell the tale
before trump was a thing i mean he
showed up that's what the spin was
uh when it really became popular because
it became popular in what 2000
well yeah and i think it was sort of
this a lot of liberal like you know the
kind of elites were like oh now we
understand
they're like okay this is how trump won
like you know it gave
it gave like elite liberal america this
like
sense of oh okay so jd vance is running
for
rob portman's seats rob portman in ohio
senators are tiring
um this is a seat that our friend tim
ryan is running for in the democratic
primary and our buddy
eric sanchez has worked for him too
portman's a republican so the senator
who's retiring is a republican
so the question is can the democrats
flip that seat could tim ryan in theory
flip it so it can
it's really we're talking about because
jd vance is going to come win the
republican primary
and then is tim ryan going to kim tim
ryan beat him so jd vance to me i
remember him speaking at
um events i would go to when i was in
the my wall street days
and to carly's point it was like he was
coming out of this conservative bubble
um in his own words hillbilly world um
in some in some sense and talking about
what it's like to grow up that way and
then he was essentially catering to the
elites and
the frankly more liberal elites
establishment um they loved him
they loved him they were like thank you
for speaking they gave him a movie deal
they would invite him all his events i'm
sure he got a bunch of money speaking to
her so he's been doing this thing right
the movie was apparently really bad by
the way it was panned
i did not see it i actually watched i
think i watched the beginning and i was
like i don't like this so he's been
doing this
i'm the lefties right winger if you will
um and then now he's been
um he said some things critical of
presidential president trump
in that world um and now he's running
for office um and he's had a really
rough go of it in the first couple days
so during his announcement
speech the the placard the sign in front
of the podium that says your name and
why you're running
fell down mid-speech did you see this
carly yeah
okay so quick story i feel bad for his
staff
so bad so i want to say this when we
were jd vancouver
put that sign there himself so some poor
schmuck who's working for jd fans it's
like this was my one job
and when you're the speaker and the sign
falls you can't it's not like in your
it's not like in your radar really it's
either behind you or in this case in
front of you in front of the podium so
you can't really tell people are
laughing you can't tell it's so awkward
don't uncomfortable
but when we were running froli andrew
frawley was our uh digital director he
ended up being our merch
merch director um kind of created a math
hats and such a really smart guy
he was like he was like in the early
days we were hanging up a yang 2020
banner behind andrew
and he had used like an excessive amount
of tape and like string like get it up
there like probably like
really got that sign locked down he's
like dude
number one rule if you've got a sign it
cannot
fall down and he told me a story where
he did this conference and like no one
showed up and it was so sad
and then to top it off like at this like
eight-person event supposed to be like a
hundred percent like super pathetic
event you told me
in the middle of someone's speech like
the sign fell down and just like
epitomized
a lame yeah like bad conferences in some
like hotels
so this happened on the poor guy's
launch speech which is horrible
yeah he's gotten some bad press then
additionally because
he's walking back the critical tweets
he'd made of president trump now these
tweets were in like 2016
and it was like oh trump is
reprehensible for his comments on
immigrants and you know muslims and
you know people from mexico and whatever
and um
that's it like these weren't even it
wasn't like he aggressively trolled
trump for the last eight you know for
four years or whatever this was in the
early days of trump running
that he had some of these tweets and now
he's like backtracking on them clearly
in a bid to court
not just trump voters but trump's
endorsement he flew out to mar-a-lago
to try and get trump's endorsement so
he's really trying to run in this trump
lane and of course the
the press politico and stuff is like
this is pathetic trump friendly lane
right and one of the things with these
republican primaries
is that if a bunch of people are running
which in a lot of states and a contested
and their seats are open there's going
to be a bunch of people running
trump will be the king maker because no
one's gonna know who's who
they're all gonna be unnamed trump's
gonna say i endorse so-and-so and i'll
do rally for so-and-so and that will tip
the scale and that's
what is frustrating to me is and we're
always gonna have this like outsiders
insider's perspective on politics like
we worked in politics for a bit we still
don't know what the hell is going on
we're not political
we're pretty dismayed by the entire
system frankly but we haven't
outsiders are yes but we know enough to
know what the hell is happening
um and what's frustrating to me is like
if you're jd vance
you're entering this race you have to
know that trump's gonna be the king
maker in your race
you have to know that so either you
start doing this stuff beforehand or
you don't enter the race because your
lane
is lefty righties your lane is the
elites like you you're gonna get the
moderate dimms
the elites have not liked jd vance for a
while to be honest and really
because he made two comments on twitter
i i think just in general
he he very quickly fell out of favor
he's a true republican like i think in
the early days when his book first came
out and it was like
oh he's helping to explain trump he's a
republican sort of like
there were i don't know he's totally one
of us but like he went to yale law like
it was that kind of we approve of this
guy we sanction this guy he's kind of
explaining to us
like you know poor white america but
like
for a while now he's clearly been a
conservative he's been on fox news like
democrats have not
and and honestly like people hated that
movie which not that that should reflect
poorly on him but it was sort of like
nothing happened
oh poor little white guy okay like you
didn't know what fork to use there's way
more
you know trauma in the world that people
face you know trying to rise from
where they came from to yale law so i
don't think he i i
and i don't think i think he does know
that trump is his lane
clearly he's doing everything he can to
court that lane he's apologizing the
fact that he said trump's thing was
reprehensible
and he made those tweets in 2016 clearly
before he knew he was going to run for
ohio senate so i i think he's
i think he's doing everything quote
unquote right for what he's trying to do
and it'll be very interesting to see how
it plays out um and
and if he's able to win trump's
endorsement or if somebody else snags it
or how that
that all goes and uh all i can say is go
tim ryan
i will i agree i will say like look
local politics very different than
national politics and state politics
very different in city politics like
it's one thing where you believe any
press is good press and i've always been
a fan of that
except on a local level it gets
different where it's
um if that press is cutting in a wrong
direction that people on a local level
are state level hate
who knows so not if you're a republican
though right like republican voters
but if you're if you're republican and a
primary and you're all the press coming
at you is about how you're apologizing
you're not like
trumpian enough there
the press is not that he's not trumpian
enough though per se i mean i guess
you're saying that's the implication
like but my point is that politico
coming after jd vance
because he's apologized for criticizing
donald trump
is not hurting the republican him in the
republican primary
republican primary voters don't care
about what politico and the new york
times are saying
here is my jd vance hillbilly elegy
insight if i may give it was i read
hillbilly elegy
2017 probably around when it came out
and i read it this
like around the same time as i read who
thought this was a good idea
which is alissa master monaco's first
book she was
she's obama's comments deputy no she was
a deputy
et cetera et cetera she was yeah she was
the scheduling and advanced director on
obama's
presidential okay and it was so
interesting because
jd vance talked about working at a
general store or grocery store-esque
you know whatever institution in
his small town in appalachia and how he
would see these folks coming in
on their cell phones and you know with
all this technology that he and his
family couldn't afford
and then they would go up to the
register and they would buy
their groceries and their beer and
whatever with food stamps and it made
him
feel very critically towards the welfare
system because he felt like all these
people
who he knew were intentionally not
seeking work who were
you know using food stamps for all sorts
of things they weren't supposed to be in
all sorts of nefarious ways etc
were had all these things that he and
his family couldn't afford because they
were living honestly
right and so he left that experience
being like
more conservative i don't like our
welfare system
alyssa master monica worked at a grocery
store when she was
younger she wrote about this and who
thought this was a good idea and she had
people come through
using food stamps and she had the exact
opposite reaction which
she had so much empathy she saw how
embarrassed people were
and how much it it it made them feel
small and less than and
etcetera et cetera and how much they
struggled to scrape together what they
could from food stamps to feed their
kids
and so it made her more liberal and i
think that's just such an interesting
you know study in like how you can have
these two experiences that are
many ways identical and come away with
these two very different takeaways
both of which are frankly legitimate
both of those are legitimate takeaways
now i obviously
lean liberal and i i end up where
melissa master monaco does but
um i don't think jd vance's perspective
on that was illegitimate
that's jonathan hates saying a lot of us
are wired to lean one way or the other
um which is a good point like it's not
about which way you naturally go it's
about trying to understand
both yourself and others
are you tired of podcast advertisements
putting you to sleep
like this one then you should probably
get a helix mattress
no seriously i got a helix mattress six
months ago and they advertise as and
they tell me to read that it's the best
night of sleep and the best mattress
you'll have but i'm be honest with you
they are not lying this mattress is
incredible so how it works
is you go on this quiz on their website
it takes two minutes to complete and
matches your body type and sleep
preferences with the perfect mattress
for you so whether you like it soft or
firm
or you sleep on your side or your back
you turn your neck you sleep hot or cold
there's a helix specific mattress for
each and everybody's unique tastes
so we've got the helix lux model and i
got the uber like king size mega thing
um and i sleep on my side so it's
customized for that and i freaking
love it so it shows up super easy
comes in a small box it pops up it
inflates and it's the best night's sleep
you're gonna have on a mattress it's
awesome so here's the deal go to
helixsleep.com and take their two-minute
sleep quiz
and right now helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com
that's helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
slash yang for up to 200 off and two
free pillows check it out right now
i think a lot of people have very strong
thoughts on this
and we don't talk about it enough i want
to talk about the concept of
making one's bed oh my god
this is where
and we talk about life and this is one
that's important so this is so pathetic
some people make their bed and others
don't and actually we should look this
up
okay most people do not do it um
thirty-seven percent of people say they
make their bed and then there's
something
sometimes you're already you're already
doing you're already doing two black and
white because it's not just do you make
your bed or do you not it's do your make
do you make your bed every single day
do you make your bed a lot of the time
but not every day
or do you not make your bed like those
are sort of your categories
so i am on the side of things where i'm
on the side where i believe you should
always make your bed
because here's why if you're going to
accomplish anything you have to
accomplish one thing first and making
your bed is first thing you accomplish
and then you can start accomplishing
other things and the other thing if you
have a rough day
you can come home and you got a nice
lovely made bed to be in
and there are certain people
particularly carly riley who think this
is illogical i'm not like
anti-making the bed here's where the
illogicalness comes in right
i do not like
accomplish less in my day because my bed
was not made
so that's where i say there's no actual
logical reason
to have to make your bed this is an
emotional response thing
that for some people works very well so
apparently for zachary
like he's just emotionally on a better
page if he knows the bed is made that's
where i come down so i would love to
know what other people think on this
do you make the bed every single day oh
and within the first 30 minutes because
if you make it like in the afternoon for
example that's
unacceptable we wake up get it out of
the way you make it a must it's like
brushing your teeth it's like putting on
deodorant it's just like a part
no okay good logical there are hot
much more logical reasons to brush your
teeth and put on deodorant this is
exactly
where you and i start to disagree right
so brush on your teeth is
hygienic reasons you need to take care
of your teeth or they will fall out and
you won't be able to eat food and you'll
die at
40 right like like there are actual
reasons you need to brush your teeth
that are very logical and about your own
health so sound off
team um come at us do are you a bed
maker are you
every day or just
always sometimes rarely never yes um
always sometimes rarely never where are
you on the bed making sense where are
you on the bed making
and i would like your comments if you do
support the making bed all the time
please let me know
give me that solidarity okay making the
bed crew people are gonna be like it's
logical to make your bed because like
humans
are awesome no because like human
reactions are such that
like oh yeah people are involuntary that
they feel good
not for me though i don't know i'm an
anomaly well i'll talk about shikari
richardson
um she is our best female runner in the
olympics
um upcoming olympics and she was
disqualified for the
from the olympics because she tested
positive for thc
or marijuana um and it's been really
interesting
to me to watch this because people have
come down
very strongly on one side so what i want
to do with like having things
and having topics on the show is when
people are like freaking out about
something like have a rational
conversation about it people have come
down very strongly on either side
um and i'm curious your thoughts carly
but it seems like this on one hand
um this is my sense of the argument on
one hand this is ridiculous she said she
was using i think she took a brownie
because she um
was grieving her grandmother um her
stepmother it was like um
yeah okay so she's grieving so on one
hand like it's freaking marijuana like
uh you know particularly this is like
from the games to begin with and then on
the
and in addition like it's it's not
actually a performance enhancing drug if
anything it slows you down right so
um like this is red so on one hand
fundamentally this is a ridiculous rule
agree with i think
i think most people can agree with that
unless you're very anti
marijuana on the other hand and i think
that's where eileen is that is what joe
biden said is that um
but it is a rule like rules are rules um
and if you want to compete in the
olympics you have to follow the rules
they set even if they're stupid and
archaic
um they're not particularly
i don't know if you could argue if
they're harming you or not but they are
the rules you agreed to play by these
rules in order to run in the race um and
people are very very strong and it's um
some of the comments been racially
fueled um which i understand
um i don't i love your thoughts carly
and then i guess i'll dive into my more
my opinion um
thoughts on the rule here and thoughts
on
um shikari's situation i think on the
micro level
i don't think there's there's racism at
play here in that this rule would
obviously have been
i believe very equally administered if
it had been a white player who had done
this i think
he or she would be facing the same
punishment you and i have talked about
there's been examples in football and
other sports where you've had
white players punished for smoking
marijuana on the macro level
there's a very real question to be had
around
how much we've criminalized marijuana in
this country and in the world at large
as a way to specifically be able to
incarcerate black people you know like
on some level and so there is this
broader criminalizing marijuana thing
that
feels like it is racist and obviously
has been used
in very racist ways aoc called it racist
and colonial
yeah you know that again
i think there's a macro argument to be
made there i think in this
specific instance i'm i'm with you like
these are the rules
i have a ton of empathy for her though
being like look i'm human and i did this
and i'm i'm i'm surprised too i mean
presumably she was very aware of the
rules
and knew she was going to be tested so
it just goes to show how much pain she
must have been in and i really empathize
with that
i also will say like so in this this
particular case i don't think
like you know on that there's a micro
level racism here
relatedly though there's this whole
there's another controversy around
um the olympics banning certain swim
caps
that better fit black black women in
particular black black
people in general but because of their
hair and you had the olympic committee
saying like
oh these swim caps aren't the natural
shape of a human head
and therefore they're banned yeah and
that's clearly racist and insane and i
don't know where we'll end up on that i
mean i just
say clearly we need to allow these swim
caps to be used
but i think those are two examples where
i come down sort of on different
different sides of them where i think
the the weed rule
again macro level there's there's
probably some racism there in our world
for sure
micro level in this particular instance
i don't think there's racism
specifically against
shikari swim cap rule crazy
totally needs to change and let's just
let that i think the uh
demonstrated that they're a bit behind
the times a bit our character a bit more
i'm sure it's like a bunch of white
people like i you know i doubt there's a
lot of diversity on the olympic
community so if that's where asu's going
i i understand i do think like
if you're an olympic athlete you know
the rules um and so like
i'm i was a josh gordon fan who was a
receiver who eventually got
suspended and then banned from the nfl
or number
i think i guess multi-year suspensions
close to banning um
for frankly just smoking too much wheat
um and he would do games like drunk and
high and still perform at a crazy elite
level um
but they banned him because those are
the rules and i don't like agree like i
think players be able to smoke marijuana
like come on
um but that is the rule um so if you i
think everybody should be up in arms
about the rule they shouldn't be up in
their
arms about this decision about the rule
being applied fairly in this case
right um yeah i agree now i don't know
and this is why i would say i don't know
enough instances
um about the racial component of this
have they
let white white athletes sneak through
the cracks on these or get more
exceptions i don't actually know
um given that they're old school
conservative um
actually i don't know i don't know my
gut would say that might
that they're probably just generally
extremely strict um
but um i don't i do feel for her that
that sucks
um this rule's horrific horrific and
frankly as an american like damn it i
wanted her to go
with her awesome hair and nails and kick
everybody's freaking ass like that would
have been
the real american thing was like yeah we
sent we sent shikari over there and
ran circles around you like hell yeah
and she can do it like looking amazing
um so that was heartbreaking because i
like to see when we win that's like when
i've always loved that so
um frustrating um i know people have
takes you can comment on us as well
last thing carl before we rock and roll
give me the free britney update because
there is news
there is news in the pop culture world
and you're my only source i refuse to
yes i refuse to give it more clicks
well you know we're we're trying to
straddle this line i'm not going to pop
culture deep because i think i'm the
only one who really wants to know like
who harry styles is dating
it's like me and the buffalo bills just
gotta give him a taste yeah yeah well
and also
the brittany movement i think also
crosses into the legal world like
there's a lot that's interesting here
so there's basically kind of two there's
two updates
i would say broadly umbrella kind of
updates there's um
what's happening with the
conservatorship and and the team
in place around the conservatorship
there's been some big moves there and
then there's sort of personal news
so this past week ronan farrow who quite
famously
like busted open a lot of the harvey
weinstein stuff ronan
and a co-author at the new yorker did a
whole
piece about the free brittany situation
and they
exposed a number of new details for
instance they they
talked to a very close family friend of
the spears's
who has been present apparently
throughout this entire process
who says that very early on um
after the conservatorship was put into
place she witnessed britney's father
like screaming at britney calling her a
fat [ __ ]
like being very verbally abusive towards
her and that she had
previously been actually somewhat in
favor of the conservatorship and then
witnessed some of that saw some other
things and is now
very opposed to the conservatorship so
they exposed some sort of family
riffs and family details like that which
were honestly all very heartbreaking
then there's big news on the conservator
side so the the judge
in this case in the current case um
ruled against
uh moving jamie spears britney's father
out of the conservatorship so jamie is
remaining a conservator um
now that that's not about whether the
conservatorship will end or not
that will be a separate but it's more
like who is the conservator however
um the judge did put a second
conservator in place to manage her
finances with jamie
and that's this bessemer trust this
professional trust group that
that does this often for different
clients what's fascinating is that the
day after essentially bessemer trust was
put in place as the co-conservator with
jamie spears
they asked to be removed and
as details have emerged it sounds like
when they were initially
approached to be the co-conservator of
this estate
they were approached by a man named sam
ingram i believe who's britney spears's
attorney
and sam had told them that this
conservatorship was voluntary and that
brittany was
fine with it and that that's why
bessemer trust had agreed to sign on and
be this co-conservator
and that after they heard britney's own
testimony in court
it was made clear to them that this was
very much not voluntary that brittany
very much wanted out of it
and so now bessemer trust wants out of
being a co-conservator
so they were misled and this is what's
very interesting by brittany's own
attorney
which feeds this whole broader narrative
right now that that sam
brittany's attorney is actually much
closer to jamie spears and despite being
britney's attorney is actually working
for a conservator more than he's working
for her
so the drama just continues the bottom
line is jamie spears will remain
conservative for the time being
but other conservators are trying to
drop out brittany's
talent manager just quit um and said he
doesn't believe brittany's gonna return
to performing basically
anytime soon and so he doesn't need him
um and
that she's probably in in a permanent
retirement so
bad news for the britney fans we will
continue to track
to bring this broadcast to bring this
podcast
full circle bill cosby is free and
britney
spears is still trapped and a prisoner
if you will
um anyway carly always pleasure
fun episode um you guys enjoy your
fourth of july
semi vacay i don't know what you call
this the week after
um enjoy the time get outside and uh
last thing on the way out
shout out to joey chesnut 76 hot dogs in
10 minutes
absolutely ridiculous guys whether you
like it or not he's an american hero he
wins it every year
he eats our food faster than anybody
else he's an american he is actually
very that is very american
hot dogs batman is an american hero love
you guys have a good week
[Music]
you